yeah hello welcome to this video I've
been doing some games on icc preferably
three minute games but somehow I know I
get get one with b3 and try to get a
solid set up here ah-huh is playing form
a double via chat about I guess I'll
take the chance to to capture and try to
destroy his pawn structure so what setup
now there's a couple of ideas that I
could go for uh-huh so it's plain d4 yet
this puts lots of pawns on dark squares
like to get them the night to f5
directly putting some pressure on deform
mmm interesting interesting question now
should i click Bishop before provokes
III will not sure maybe this is helpful
for him anyway but hard to tell yeah
okay I don't mind it's got all points on
dark squares now almost all of them and
there's no attack wats either question
is so I castle on okay Becca play this
castles by hand
to g7 the king and then probably we
should have six and c5 this would be the
idea one idea okay I have no idea what
he is doing where I see supposed to
castle maybe you just cancel short oh
yeah okay I'll prepare c5c five should
open up a way to his weaknesses on c3
yeah please take here threatening to
take on b3 oh yeah not c 3 is hanging
uh-huh so I want a porno c3 and maybe
not not directly but then yeah now I
went upon so should I just take it yeah
probably
yeah probably need to need to go back to
Radha exposed on t3i you've got queen
bee five maybe ok this one instead he
cannot take now because of rupee aid so
i'll keep my keep my extra porn question
is if i continue up the eight-hour rook
c8 c3 probably look com1 matter is
probably intending that g5 former and
not them i will just take it wherever
the night goes yeah this is just another
weakness on one b5 and ok i'll just
attack and win it i think yeah i can
cover this first and then i go around
with a king or if i simply move on now
come on just just activate the king keep
it simple yeah King to d5 then I can
take it on on b6 next move yeah maybe it
would have been even easier to to some
play play rock III ok
yeah this should should window get all
the poems it's got his heaven but this
is simply too many pawns check check
check check white forfeits on time yeah
yeah in weekend weekend disposition
rather rather early years I've got to
get this this bed structure and it's not
so easy to get anything clear going for
that all right let's see I get a couple
of more games if I don't get any
three-minute games then i'll try to get
five minute ones alright so the tricky
for me to adjust to the different speeds
but i want to get a steady flow of games
ok let's try 45 so maybe there are not
so many people online at the moment game
started oh this is a five-minute Gabby
okay so II for our play the French
experimented a bit recently put this and
get an advanced variation where I always
played Bishop d7 our cable should be
three okay I always like Brooks the ATM
you can of course take and play Queen B
6 and this is probably also good for
black but I always some preferred this
line where you get a drink get rid of
this vision quickly
uh-huh okay yeah I'll take the chance to
to activate my pieces and get something
quickly on deform so I got the lysosome
night on f5 and some activity against
the d4 pawn to be honest I think
blackest already am better here what
what is he doing a bit too is it's a
problem also and I'm probably can play
group to see for all kinds of ideas and
simply he adds almost a space advantage
uh-huh ok this is move I don't
understand at all i can simply take on
d4 is there some some trick because c3
is hanging I don't see why I shouldn't
take Queen takes Knight takes the knight
on c3 is just staying so I should turn I
should just win the central pawn I'm
term if he takes now now there's no
trick no trick at all it's just a pawn I
mean c3 is also now hanging ssf4 so if
he's got I don't think even a move to
avoid the Queen trade and I just won the
central pawn so it should them should be
M resins immediately actually ok you can
continue with the cordon yeah this
decided this is some I move that I
briefly thought there could be a problem
but take on d3 now he has got 96 but I
think I can I can just take this don't
see ya don't see any issue at all
yeah maybe yeah 25 and this was stupid
no i don't now I don't have do I win
material yeah of course I need to take
away can do this first I should have
thought about this longer I mean 25 was
certainly possible was just a pizza mmm
yeah this was unnecessary hmm yeah
stupid yeah very stupid never black
black is still are still okay but um the
other the other continuation system was
just winning for and very easily even
young stupid so what is this 3 points4
points yeah its material equality really
really silly yeah okay then i can just
take it and not much happening really
i'm attacking a to where you can just
play a for this one well maybe once play
ruger Bishop e3 on a five possible
57 hmm yeah I'm not sure a 52 should be
three it's a bit annoying complainy
should be some rock deforms not great ok
let's just cover this the rook wasn't
doing so much on this hand anyway in the
some concrete position yeah okay not
much choice an eternity to take this
it's rather similar to the two what what
I'm talked about before and completely
completely non Stephanie how did I get
into this yet was totally winning just
completely cooked nonsense what I played
there after this opening this is really
disappointing you mean like was after 70
move just winning for very easily even
oh man
yeah now i'm just a couple of points
down for absolutely nothing ya can play
on a bit but yeah simply forgot that I'm
not winning a PCM night XD 525 is just
just resins here just 25 end and white
resins complete nonsense my mega and now
for whatever reason he's not moving did
I blunder something no that didn't
doesn't look like it time warning not
sure why I spent a soul so much time at
some basically winning would every move
check
check check check
I mean it is doing everything to to make
it difficult for himself yet probably
I'm still still winning yeah yeah yeah I
resign resign yeah just stupid sometimes
you just need to must sit on your hands
for a while after this this nonsense I
just take windey five and he resigns for
nothing and i just took here and forgot
that he actually gets the piece back I
thought it was just doesn't matter how I
take just 25 and and huge lines it's
complete complete nonsense it's just a
piece alright so let's hope the next
game is a somewhat better alright a
three or five minute game
yeah no opponent really yet when I mean
to two of those carrying pools and I
don't get don't get a game this is
really a really unusual game started I'd
really love to play this guy again I
mean this was really amazing okay get a
new Mazzone and play the the reuben star
but ok let's go to the to the same ish
it always leads to interesting positions
it's sometimes a bit fishy for white but
it's a it's still interesting chest that
crops up usually quite often you see
that blacks player black players that
don't really know what to do I mean this
what what this black player here so
going for so so it's almost unplayable
oh also I just get them a full center
here with two bishops don't really see
em where his waist compensation is not
shown doesn't get any good pressure on
the e porn yeah the question is if I can
if I can play even before now so very
often this is possible as some blacks
development so bad de fé 94 and then
Bishop c4 for example but here's got not
have 60 s probably not not working yet
but I can play rook e1 and then and then
you form yeah II for next move
yeah really curious not sure what blacks
ideas maybe he's got them something
technical going button that I don't
understand possible strategically black
ass is lost now really full Center to
bishops the a frightening G for winning
a piece not not sure what is black doing
to save as 90m thought maybe could not
be six instead of this this move might
be 64 we are now G for some quite them
quite a big threat design yeah I don't
see anything else I mean computer also
says that it's a peace cannot prevent
this but then this position already is
it's really horrible I mean 96's it's
the only thing imaginable that you that
you can do probably this is the still
playable but it's it's it's a it's risky
to two bishops and so on okay so let's
try it to get a new game three or five
minutes and I don't want anything like
that French Cape again game started okay
so what let's play let's play a 44
change our great something I have no
idea about Vallecano Aloha defense I'm
not complaining prob'ly I'm butchering
up the pronunciation again c6 yeah this
is some a pretty good line for black so
rather solid and I have of course no
no real idea i know that usually you you
better retreat trying to keep more
pieces on the board yeah blacks ideas to
get this fish about and then e64 going
for rather normal-looking development
yeah this is certainly rather solid for
black you should never be any should
never be seriously worse I'm going for a
solid set up as well want to get the
night to see form yeah yeah I expect c5
of course I thought it would be not too
bad for me if he would take 94 this
shouldn't be too bad so um I thought
this could be an idea putting some
slight pressure unknown on the beep on
so if you take some I can I can
recapture with the night I mean you yeah
I'm thinking about 93 is this an idea it
doesn't doesn't really bring much much
benefits g3 and probably g3 the bishop
is certainly good on g2 and only need to
be cautious that it the night isn't
hanging on on c4 yeah exactly now feel
that he probably threatens to to take it
so let's drop the knife back
and i also need to be aware that this is
the three minute game quite important so
I haven't owned and plate really really
quickly yeah almost a minute down which
is quite a lot here and of course I
don't have anything it's got them got a
pretty pretty good position now you can
you can take on a three now I take the
foil and you hope that okay mr. Fitz
repeating you certainly won't make a
draw now could be weird with them the
time advantage I'd like it certainly
okay yeah it's hard for me to fit to
avoid the repetition crime this is weird
he just drew the game for three points
yeah yeah but i don't know i don't have
anything else I mean I can go to d1 back
to d1 but this is silly yeah just a bad
opening for me I don't know the sand
don't know this stuff I mean I don't not
only for play about harder can I can't
play it and I know a bit of Maya mostly
I know stuff about the openings that
I've that i play with black young like
an obit of God Sicilian and a bit about
the French with stuff like Allah hunts
defense i don't know i played this even
but it's years ago and i forgot all of
it okay so playing against the women
international master from israel much
sure let's have a look if there's a name
in there olga wassily f no no idea i
don't know where ok so i'll play the
sameish and see what what line is coming
now Lex got the white choice the other
the Benoni set up
with 97 early whom I probably cannot
avoid to go here anyway so let's do it
now yeah this is always curious this
earlier each forum at age five moves
trying to disturb the night probably
need to go to f1 but it's always
questionable at this gh5 h4 if the sun
is really beneficial to black it also
can be a very weakening term it is
really a double a really double edged
down kind of approach now I can go to h1
which is a pretty good square funny
enough simply because it through to f2
want to go to f2 whether nidus nicely
placed and multi5 I'd like to avoid
hurting one problem for black is him he
knows she she never played e6 and
actually exchanged on d5 so if you would
play is six now then f four leaves the
Knights really embarrassed so I just
play Knight f2 and now probably that's
the idea form g4 is covered now what on
f4 well where do you go this is Sarah
will probably have need two Desperados
sacrifice now this night is just gone
this was one problem if you like it
didn't have this gap this is not a
stable position for peaceably so I just
want to pawn question is how to
keep legs play to a minimum probably
here can also go to d3 but you for as
protected by this night yeah probably
best to jump all the way back and then
night d to see form need to locate on c4
this master should be enough yeah night
see for next yeah five yeah but I should
be able to play in 50 but I don't need
to way I've got see form I've got c4
nicely nicely located should I play
Bishop b3 even hmm I can also just take
I mean not not clear I mean it's it's
about it's a piece piece in any case
just a matter of trying to keep keep
later to a minimum yeah okay but should
be three preventing we should d for kind
of kind of ideas c4 night is just great
covering v2 and blocking this 221
majority yeah i can just overprotective
five for me also 22 yeah I know if I
thought gee for shelter should be good
the king is nicely placed on the edge
file so i can play king g 20 gauge one
and even get an attack on the H file
threatening g45 also now we are looks
like nice controlled blackheads no no
player whatsoever yeah an extra pieces
some service is helpful
yeah probably who ya was what with that
can also take two times ok let's grab
with this first down boo catch one so
now look H form yeah it should be enough
look aged from the take just eat eggs
our queen takes and so everything's
under control cut row gauge one next and
also Bishop g4 e6 so another possibility
yeah like this is gone really I first
Earth strengthen this a bit not quite
sure what watch is aiming for it's
really a completely over check
I mean house on the book is hanging on
f7 okay first Knight a5 and then take
the rook like this doesn't even have a
check and I can also not recapture after
taking on f7 because h6 is hanging so
Quincy to maybe Quincy to threatening on
g6 and if black takes on f7 I take h6 I
mean ever everything's where everything
winds basically
you
check these have unless um I don't see
how to cover this time warning hmm okay
let's mmm ticket once more just taking
them okay once the Queen for a reason
yeah okay yeah okay she just blunder to
PCM you know this position is a bit
tricky I think because what black wants
to do is to play six really e6 taking b5
stuff like that and if you go e 60 in
this position let's go back a couple of
moves if you go six here i have a form
and this this is just not not working
you can drop back and then d 6 is gone
so i think black has delayed this is six
move for for too long really i mean 9f
to now need to play Strange moves now I
think to avoid being worse is f-4s right
knee okay Bishop d7 just gives it away
completely but um it's it's a bit tricky
already okay so let's drive folder okay
this is not three minute game Grand
Master will try risk let's change let's
check is known name in there what is
this guy lost an uncle Stan okay yeah
okay let's play 3 and a 3 probably okay
and can be 6i I can still play three
come on let's play the the same it's
always always interesting we have lost
my share of drastic games with white but
also had some very memorable attacking
wins oops alone this one so we transpose
into a normal line you know like if I
perform no black usually goes f5 exactly
and skokie five
somehow something strange here compared
to the line that that i usually get here
and I'm not sure at all something's
weird here losing a piece i was losing
and losing upon it's not the weird part
this is rather normal but somehow it's I
know am i lacking a movie or something
it's strange very often what I don't the
idea is to push d six year d 56 and this
would kill the eighth night this is the
the position idea but somehow I I don't
have I don't have the time to do that
and now I have you just allowed this
which isn't a terrible i am just a
thought i would leave managed to to get
this farm yeah the black problem is here
for black is that this night on e 8 has
no no squares absolutely no and his only
idea really is supplier is g5 or
something if I can play night they're
not be too i can take and then this is
probably not bad yeah i don't mind this
exchange this is her completely all
right i want to open up the queenside
because i'm playing with with extra
material there
the time versus me a bit to be honest
I've been been to too quickly too quick
off quickly time one yeah I'd like to
have more time here i'm pretty sure that
this position should be good for me he's
simply playing without a piece and a
hard time believing what this is should
be any good guys got 35 this is so the
idea
my problem is the time more than
anything else probably rule before now
take him I'd landed this the spawn ah
this is costly hmm shame of course there
should blunder the spawn that's probably
still not clear I've got rook one to be
seven coming but I have no time yeah
shame this would would have been nice in
a longer time control at least let's say
five to fifteen minute even this isn't
isn't so clear I mean as I have a deep
one and what is he doing here
yeah okay yeah I only had three seconds
left probably this position was it was
very good for white I mean this is cat
can't be good for black but the
impossible just pretty sure the computer
126 now probably when Sam okay and
before it was it was completely this was
very good for white the computer
obviously doesn't understand the
position it gives minus one and what
this is not correct why does excellent
am I just need to get to get the pants
back on the queenside is playing without
an ID and without a look also it's um I
just don't know we need to prepare all
this a bit better Queen a free yeah
Queen a free sub computer suggestion you
now have two points down i understand
but these pieces are not working
especially the night is not working yeah
it's tricky it's tricky in this time
okay so um it's a 40 minute video um
maybe I wonder one more gala
three-member through one more three
minute game and then i'll call it a dame
okay let's try something else i can
place the bank or himself here and maybe
I let's play when only for a change i
have no idea especially if you place one
of the sharper lines like a form yeah
this is also even also drinking I know
that this this kind of you guys is this
I don't know details Nagi 3m looks very
strange
so this is just winning here yeah okay
but I've got Bishop d4 also can I g3 is
really strange move it's not clear I can
you can probably now maybe you can take
26 even you should be for who and now
what let's not clear I'd be five it's
also possible possibility cause he
didn't plan any of this it's um just a
good coincidentally happening so the
same so I cannot really am cover the Sun
in Bishop b5 is just so ugly yeah maybe
just continue developing we should be
six rupee a dork of 95 coming and all
kinds of stuff yeah
yeah thought of everything else fails to
play Knight f6 but then he has got a 5k
I give this check first and then see
what happens King edge one probably yeah
there's Nigel yeah this looks looks
really shaky but to be honest really
shake him now yeah I can play we should
be free now so this was the idea of this
the stuff not sure if it's working but
what's the idea so we can take down here
and play Knight reform so it's um I only
have two points really time warning so
surprising so it probably will sacrifice
exchange now because he wants Bishop c4
I guess to support the bond yeah
yeah yeah it's not easy at all I need to
get out of this style of you of course
whoops yeah this is the way to do this p
overlooks this simple moves ah What
nonsense ok this is medium Bishop ever
Bishop f4 king edge five Bishop e2 King
H form yeah this is checkmate yeah this
was bad shot me yeah go on I didn't play
too great then of course after this
stuff black should really win the game I
mean is this is this in any way playable
I mean this would be amazing our
computer gives white an advantage this
is great cacapon in place complete
nonsense with a bindle a g3 overlooking
this and then it's then it's even good
for white this is fun yeah this is a
completely every strange move but you
know don't know i mean this this stuff
is probably completely unclear yeah the
computer ssss is winning am understand
gem the e porn is really really very
strong and this is a problem the
opponent's is very strong yeah all right
some mum some complicated and pretty
yeah games full of arrows so i hope you
enjoyed it anyway thanks for watching